[Music]
gidy Greenstein thank you for joining me
startup Nation United and it is November
2nd now so day 27 of of the war it's
important for us to capture the the ex
timing of this conversation obviously
this things are so Dynamic and are ever
changing and I think one of the most
impressive things about this is to hear
about how how quickly um impact has been
made already the beginning of of this uh
of this of this difficult time and
obviously the work that you're doing
with with Tom is remarkable and even
outside the context of the war but but
even more so your response and um an
active participation in the in the in
the efforts as part of the ecosystem so
so already um looking forward to to
hearing your story tell me just before
we dive into what you're doing today
with in the context of the war tell me a
little bit about yourself and about Tom
as well
so mik thank you very much for uh for
inviting it's actually our second
conversation about this topic another
one was I think about year and a half
ago even even I think three years ago
was a long time three years ago okay but
then to you were a student yes yes so
basically uh I grew up in Israel my
first the seventh the initial seven
years of my career was spent on Israeli
Palestinian peacemaking and the peak of
that was serving as a secretary of the
is delegation for the negotiations with
the PLO including at the cemp David
Summit with Clinton Barack Arafat all
that history that was very early in my
professional career right out of my
military
service next I launched a think tank
called spelled with an Alf in Hebrew for
your Hebrew speaking listeners and uh it
basically means the ability to see
through we dealt with the issues of
National Security and economic
development and through that I reached I
um
created this idea of Tom tun makers um
basically uh we saw that the bottom tier
of the economic ladder people who are um
they often referred to as the bottom of
the economic ladder the bottom 10 20% of
the population they are actually
structurally excluded from the benefits
of the Innova many of the benefits of
the Innovation economy as they say 90%
of the world's Innovation is targeted at
10% of the people at the top who can
actually afford it so the bottom is
deserted and the idea was uh um uh was
to create a platform and a process that
will allow a lot of innovation or our
needs of people at the bottom of the
economic ladder people with disabilities
elderly poor people um those of your
listeners who know the word DARPA the
idea was to create the DARPA of assisted
Technologies in Hebrew in Israel the
mafat social mafat that was the original
process and required creating a platform
and a process that crowdsources Talent
of engineering and design around needs
that emanate from the bottom and all the
solutions that are created are open
source and free deposited online on a
website which then allows basically
distributive manufacturing and in the
process of distributed manufacturing the
idea is that there's a lot of excess
capacity today in 3D printers most of
the 3D printers that were bought in the
last
year or decade are underused so you have
dramatic amount of manufacturing
capability that is basically scattered
around Society scattered around the
world and our idea was to as I mentioned
earlier to crowdsource the talent to
create a portfolio of Open Source and
free Solutions and then to basically uh
distribute it um all over the world both
developed and developing countries
thereby kind
of uh equalizing the access to these
Solutions between urban and rural areas
between developed and developing
countries uh Etc so that was the
original idea we've been added for a few
years and uh um and right be the this
conflict the war started October 7 we
had about 800 Solutions on our platform
in five phases of development 47 of them
were already for global distribution
meaning they were documented in a way
that allows anybody anywhere to download
the solution and manufacture it locally
so when the war
started Saturday we were all in shock as
you know Sunday still in shock Monday we
got the team on the phone and uh like a
lot of other people in Israel we said
what are we doing to help what can we do
what are the unique assets that we have
that we can deploy to uh address the the
acute needs that emerged from uh from
the war from the crisis and we wound up
focusing on two categories of needs
first is the needs of displaced families
especially those who have family members
with disabilities when they're moving
out of their home a lot of them are
leaving behind the facilities the
infrastructure that are required for
day-to-day life so for example toilet
seats for children with severe
disabilities they don't use regular
toilet seats those toilet seats are not
usually not mobile now the family is out
of the house and we wanted to create a
radically affordable alternative that
they could use wherever they are that's
project number one another project that
came in high need was a wheelchair for
toddlers again these are very expensive
pieces of equipment many families can't
afford them at all because in most cases
in most countries they're not even
covered by insurance we have a $300
solution that actually now we're going
to make it even a $200
solution um that can be manufactured and
delivered to dozens of families so these
are the kind of things that we have been
doing we have created a portfolio of
solutions for needs of displaced
families and these uh and we're
basically Distributing them Distributing
them now the second area where we're
focused on is regarding the forthcoming
wave of wounded civilians and soldiers
who are in Rehabilitation because of the
nature this conflict first of all that
Hamas people shot to kill every single
person so they always aimed at the upper
body most people many people died but
those that survived have severe injuries
the second piece is amputations because
people took for a long time it took to
evacuate the wounded a lot of
amputations so we dealing with those
situations we're basically creating a
portfolio of solutions to support the
wooden when they come out of the
rehabilitation centers and they move
back into their homes into the society
Rehabilitation and then even getting
back to their Hobbies Sports Arts music
we want to support this entire process I
want to say that my background from the
days of the peace
process uh we have been supported by
usaid toward our work between Jews and
Arabs and Israel and between Israelis
and Palestinians and I am personally and
my team we're committed to the idea of
peace with whoever we can have that
peace with and therefore all of our
Solutions are documented in English and
increasingly in Hebrew and Arabic and um
we will not let go of our friends on the
Palestinian side who are committed for
peace and they're still working with us
in spite of these very difficult uh
situation um so this is what we've been
at for the best three weeks it's been
crazy it's been devastating in many ways
personally but it's also
inspiring yeah I mean that first of all
it's incredible thank you thank you for
that how has this been for the team on
the ground so operationally you know you
mentioned Saturday shock Sunday shock
Monday we got the team on the phone and
we and we start working what has this
been like internally for Tom and the
people that are working with you in
operationalizing this for for this will
for these use cases that are so you know
IM immediate and
Urgent so we had a few people and couple
members of our team and a lot of our
volunteers who are recruited so
basically we lost a portion of our team
we lost a segment of our volunteer
network but I found that going back to
work and setting very high and ambitious
goals actually elevates people from the
condition of shock and focuses them and
drives them into action and part of what
we're dealing with now is um as I said
we lost many of our volunteers because
they were recruited we issued out a call
for volunteers people who are have
engineering skills design skills we have
more than
250 volunteers who signed up and we
basically divided them into development
teams where develop new Solutions or
upgrading existing Solutions and
Manufacturing teams those who take the
uh the mature products and are simply
manufacturing them and pushing them to
rehabilitation centers to evacuation
centers to hospitals and so on so we for
every person we lost we have 10 20
people who stepped up to seal the Gap
and I believe that the best way to
respond to this crisis mentally is to
get to work and to work really hard and
to be very ambitious and it's a huge
crisis but it's also an opportunity to
elevate our gain and if we can move
from 47 50 solutions that were ready for
distribution October 7 to having a 100
solutions by December 31 so wed
people initially in our conflict in our
crisis in Israel but then that portfolio
of solutions can help anybody anywhere
around the world just a few months ago
our friends in Turkey when there was the
big earthquake in turkey called us for
solutions that we couldn't address their
need and then a few weeks later or a
month couple of months later there was
an earthquake in Morocco and we at the
time we could not address the request
that came from Morocco by the time the
crisis ends in Israel we will have been
able to address turkey and Morocco and
God willing when we move forward we'll
be able to take the knowledge that was
created within the crisis in Israel and
deploy it everywhere around the
world yeah it's incredible
how um a terrible that's terrible
situation is you know serves for an
organization like Tom is a platform for
Innovation and creation right you know
there's a French saying the edge of the
guillotine sharpens the mind so you know
that's uh that's where we are you know
we have to respond we have to operate
everybody in Israel now um we there is a
say in Hebrew as you
know meaning every broomstick is a gun
in time of Crisis so um for example I
know you come from the world of
innovation we we developed a very unique
Innovation process in Tom that it was
basically uh relied on a five person
team three to seven person on average
five person team now we're moving to a
two person team and why because we need
so in spite of the fact that we have
many more volunteers we also have many
more needs so we are cutting down by
half the basic unit size of our
development team to be able to deal with
more needs so everything has to shift
and adapt to the radical scarcity that
we're dealing with and the tremendous
pressures of TI and the trem tremendous
demands on our operation and again I
don't want to sound too you know too
heroic about it because the other people
are dealing with much bigger needs and
much bigger problems but in our little
um you know space we are doing what we
can to
contribute to you know to the very dire
situation that our society
faces well gidy thank you for all the
amazing work you're doing this is
inspiring and awesome and I love the
passion and the energy and and
especially the forward looking at how
this H this is you know the um you know
this is is really a catalyst for your
Innovation and for um for your then
contribution to other conflicts and that
this is a part of I think the story of
the startup nation and we deal with our
deal we deal with the situation we
manage it we have to because we there's
no other option you will help these
people that need assistance because that
is the mission you set out to do and in
doing so you're innovating in a capacity
that allows you to then bring this to
other people as well which is phenomenal
yeah okay just in one more sentence
share with you um so this week was three
years since the passing of Rabbi Lord
Jonathan saxs who was a giant Rabbi and
U um really a philosopher about humanity
and uh people know him as a rabbi and
Lord he's also the winner of the
Templeton prize which is like the Nobel
Prize for philosophy this is how giant
Rabbi saaks was and uh there's a a good
u a very important quote that I always
use from one by saxs isak said the best
way to heal a broken Society is to build
things together and that's what we try
to do working across religious political
National lines building things together
for the sake of humanity and I think
that right now we in Israel we
experienced a shock to our humanitarian
values a shock to our perception of uh
of of human relations and uh and Human
Condition and and and so on but the some
of but many of us still
believe that we can reach out across
borders and build relations with people
who are willing to accept us and uh uh
and that's what we're trying to do we
believe that if we build things together
we can build Bridges and relationships
and we hope that uh that will be part of
the story of at some point peacemaking
when this war is over and that horrible
enemy that we have is out of the way
hopefully we can do
that thank you so much thank you very
very much for having
[Laughter]
me